I have here a pipe of sorts. I blow in
air here and air kinda comes out through this spout.
Just so that you are convinced the air is coming out, watch.
The air is coming out, okay.
Now, I'm going to put this very light
ball just above the spout, okay?
And blow on it.
The upward streaming air is supporting the weight of the ball, so that it's in levitation, it's floating in the middle of the air.
So far so good. But now,
I can support it completely off the vertical.
Let's see if I can do it in the other direction too.
Did you see that while it's off the vertical the ball is spinning?
This phenomenon has to do with all sorts of questions, a whole range of questions that are often discussed in popular literature, and technical literature,
and, has to do with, for example, how a plane flies.
Now, the usual explanation is that it's Bernoulli's theorem.
That's the technical term that people always invoke. And it's supposed to say that if you have a flow of fluid;
air, water what have you.
The sum of
density times velocity squared over two, so speed squared plus the pressure, is supposed to be constant.
So, if there's a large speed, there's small pressure. And if there's a large pressure there's small speed.
And they'll say, they'll have you believe, that well
there's fast airflow on this side,
and there's slow airflow on this side. So the fast side has low pressure and the slow side has high pressure.
So the high pressure region is pushing the low pressure region, and so it's going to
be lifted in this direction, fighting the gravitational force.
And they will say that that's the same thing why the airplane's flying.
Now this is not quite right, because Bernoulli's theorem, if you read the actual proof and the statement and so on,
says that for each stream line, that is, the flow line of say fluid particles, that's true.
But, you cannot apply it automatically to different stream lines.
And in this case, there is a stream line coming above the ball and there's a stream line below the ball.
But these are different stream lines, you can't apply Bernoulli to both at the same time.
You can't say, "well, this stream line and this stream line, they have the same kind of constant".
No, it's not implied in the theorem.
There is another version of Bernoulli, which is called a time-dependent Bernoulli, for potential flow.
Which means that if there is no vortex in the system you can apply Bernoulli to the entire fluid region.
But, in this case there's a lot of vortex, you saw the whole thing's spinning. So you cannot apply Bernoulli there either.
So, it's actually a non
application. You can't use Bernoulli to explain this.
So, what is happening, is the question. What is really
happening has to do with something that is subtle but is in some sense even more primitive than Bernoulli.
You see when we do this:
air is streaming above the ball and is being deflected along the ball like this.
Why does it deflect? Because the air has to stick to the ball.
And in a fluid, it's a continuum, it doesn't want to, sort of, snap out and create a vacuum.
So if there's a solid boundary, for example, some body like this, it wants to go along the boundary of this thing.
And that's why it gets deflected. And underneath it kind of goes like that also. So the long and short of it is
that the whole air flow comes in like this, but goes out like this. So it curved.
But whenever the trajectory of a moving object curves, for example, in fluid curves, there must be a force that's curving it. You know? And that force is being supplied by
the ball.
Because ball is leading the fluid around this. Because the fluid wants to cohere, that's the technical term,
and wants to go around the ball.
Well action and reaction. If nature has produced one effect,
it has to pay for it by having a countereffect;
and the reaction is from the fluid, the surrounding fluid, the air, to the ball.
And if the ball has supplied this kind of force, in order to deflect the airflow, the air has to supply the counter-force in order
to lift the ball.
So whenever there is
a curvature of the flow line
that creates what we call the pressure gradient. If it's curving like this, the inner part has high pressure and outer part has low pressure.
And, mathematically speaking, it's really related with centrifugal force.
So centrifugal force for speed v, is like v squared over r, r is the sort of radius of this curvature,
and that's actually the pressure gradient that you are creating.
So the, again, long and short of it is because you have a high pressure region low pressure region, it's going to be lifted upward.
The ball is providing this
deflecting, a curving trajectory.
So the ambient fluid
has to apply a force which compensates for that, which is in this direction.
And this is really an effect of a curving trajectory of any kind.
So if you have a curving trajectory, for example
the radius of this curvature is r, and it's going at the speed v, and it's going around;
it turns out that there is a centrifugal force which is like this. And let's say rho is the density.
And this is the pressure gradient, which increases as you go from in to out. That's what the minus sign is.
(Brady: So Professor the, the, the ball-)
Yes?
(Brady: -turned the air around the corner? Like it made the, it made the air change direction?)
Yes.
(Brady: So the air gets its revenge in a way, doesn't it?)
- Yes, that's right.
(Well if you're gonna do that then I'm gonna push you the opposite direction.)
That's a very good language!
(But for the air to get its revenge it has to touch the ball. Like it has to be able to punch it.)
(So where is the air punching the ball?)
(Is it from underneath or-?)
Yes.
(Because it can't pull it, can it? Because it hasn't got like hooks or anything that can pull with?)
Well, it can pull because, you see, the - if you have air next to the ball and air leaves the ball;
well, if it can just freely leave the ball
it's going to leave a vacuum behind. But the fact of the matter is the fluid next to the solid;
it doesn't want to create a vacuum.
It doesn't want a cavity. It wants to sort of cohere. It wants to fill the whole space with some substance.
So, when it's pulling away, by that very effect it's actually pulling the solid as well.
And, on the molecular level, it's clear what's happening. You know, molecules are all attracting each other.
All the air molecules are kind of connected by springs to neighbouring regions. And when you pull the spring,
that spring, you know, shrinks and then pulls the whole thing in. And similarly if you push the spring it gets compressed and that's what the pressure is.
(Brady: So Professor, as a mathematician and a physicist,)
(when you're sitting on a plane flying to Japan and you look out the window and you see the wing-)
Yeah?
(-in your head are you imagining the wing being pulled up by the air or pushed up by the air?)
Well, I think it's both. You see the wing is so designed that,
roughly speaking, the air comes in like thi-, sorry. Air comes in like this and goes out like that.
So it's current is, the trajectory is deflected. And that creates two effects, both which are conspiring of course, that the air underneath is
pushing upward and the air above is pulling.
That's a figurative way of speaking but essentially, again, what's going on is that there is a pressure difference.
And you have an effect from high pressure region to low pressure region,
you are pushing against each other. By the way, pressure is, everyone knows, is force divided by area. If you multiply top and bottom,
numerator and denominator, by length, you get force times length, that's called work, that's a form of energy. And area times length, that's volume.
So it's actually energy per volume.
Pressure is like potential energy per volume,
and we're saying that if you have a high pressure region, that's high potential energy region, and low potential energy region which is low pressure region,
then the stuff moves - is pushed from high pressure to low pressure.
Which is exactly the same thing as if you have a, say, a slope like this;
a hill and a valley, where all the balls wants to roll from high potential region to the low potential region. Just rolls down.
And it gains some kinetic energy by doing this. So the pressure is acting like the potential energy.
Let's, let's do the spoon, actually. So let's go. Yeah, let's do the spoon because I like your, um,
language of the taking revenge.
That's great, that's wonderful.
So, you can do another home experiment to see that whenever a fluid flow
curves, the trajectory of the fluid curves, it creates a pressure gradient.
Difference in pressure, which sucks
something in on one side and pushes something out on the other side.
As soon as the spoon touches the water, the water gets
deflected, you see? From straight vertical down, to the side. And that has the effect of
pulling the spoon in. You see that? Poof!
And that's because, if the water momentum is changed from this to this, that means that somebody must be
providing the force from left to right and the counter force is applied to the spoon
from right to left and that sucks in the spoon from this side.
And if I touch the spoon - the water with the spoon from this side, it's the opposite effect.
(Brady: So you can feel that spoon being pulled like a wing?)
Yeah. And that's essentially like the ball, but the picture is seen sideways. You see the
airflow was coming in like this and going out like this. And if you turn it by 90 degrees, it's exactly the same picture.
And this is the ball, which is sucked in the direction opposite to the direction of deviation of the fluid flow.
[Preview] You see, there's a cup here. And the challenge is to just tuck the ball up and put it in a cup. Now,
that's of course very, very difficult to do so you shouldn't do this in public,
because the chances of success are very small.